hey guys it's max it has been one week
since i switched
from the iphone 12 pro to the brand new
12 pro max and in this video
i'll tell you every real world
difference that i found
both the positives and the negatives of
both phones
some that i was expecting and a few that
really blew me away
and in the end of the day which one of
these two
i'm gonna keep as my daily driver and
why
let's jump right in and cover the
biggest concern that people have
when considering buying the max model
and that is
comfort now i have to say when i first
got the regular 12 pro in my hand
about a month ago i was surprised by a
couple things first off
the flat edges felt really great in the
hand a lot better than i expected
but with that it felt a lot bulkier than
the previous
iphones the 12 pros and the regular 12s
are actually a lot thinner than the 11s
but it doesn't feel like it because when
you wrap your hand around the phone
you just feel way more contact on the
sides and that made me
really nervous for the 12 pro max model
now this is where it gets
interesting when i put this one in my
hand i was shocked that it didn't feel
as bulky as i expected maybe i just
thought it was going to be too crazy
but i feel like with this larger phone
in your hand not wrapping around as much
as the smaller phones
it actually feels more comfortable than
the 11 pro max
with that phone and its rounded edges it
just felt like it was going to
constantly slip out of my hand and the
12 pro max model
even though has a larger screen it feels
a lot more comfortable and secure
in my hand which i was not expecting so
comparing these two
the difference is much smaller than i
expected
and it's no longer a deal breaker for me
next let's go ahead and talk about the
design obviously these things look
almost
identical the 12 pro max does have a
larger camera bump
and other than that the only thing i
noticed is that the actual lenses
themselves
in the glass it sticks out quite a bit
more than the regular 12 pro and then
some of my jeans the skinnier ones i
actually feel the camera bumps pushing
against my leg which i didn't with the
12 pro it's not a huge deal
but i did want to mention that now the
other difference that i noticed
is with the colors i have the regular
silver version for the 12 pro and i have
the gold for the 12 pro max
and with the regular one the silver
after about a week or even maybe five
days or so i started noticing a bunch of
micro scratches
all around on the frame now the 12 pro
max it's been a week
and i'm not seeing anything the coating
on the gold
seems to be much tougher than the silver
one
now the last thing i really want to
mention is the wallet
now personally i really like the wallet
and with the 12 pro
i used it for about a week week and a
half and i absolutely
loved it it fills up almost the whole
back and when i grab
the phone it actually feels a little bit
more comfortable in my hand and it
actually stays pretty secure i've never
had it actually fall off putting it into
my pocket or taking it out
with that said it's using it in the past
week with the 12 pro max
you guys can see how much room is around
on the edges now when i put my hand
around it
it doesn't really do much for me because
the phone is wider
my hand actually doesn't make that much
contact with the wallet
and then with that i'm having much more
issues
with the wallet slipping off and then
when i take it off it feels totally fine
it feels just as comfortable it doesn't
add any
comfort which is weird saying that as it
does with the 12
pro and just to add on to that if you
have one of the iphone 12 minis
it actually fits perfectly with the
frame of the phone
and this thing is so secure on the small
phone because you can't easily push up
against it or up
that it just feels amazing if you have a
12 mini but the pro max
not so much and now let's get into this
place and the difference
is shocking you might think that 6.1
inches isn't that much smaller than 6.7
but when you start using these the 12
pro max really stands out
every time i pull this phone out and i
look at the display i start using it
i'm just surprised by how large it is
and how nice it is um now
as far as productivity and with that i
mean email
web browsing there's really not that
much of a difference other than just
everything being
bigger you don't really benefit that
much from that screen size
where it really starts to come in is if
you're watching
videos now it's not a massive difference
but you definitely
notice it especially if you're actually
switching over to say like a movie
and with that one difference that i
thought there could be
is speakers i thought the larger phone
could have better sound but in reality i
didn't notice any difference both sound
just as loud
the quality sounds just as good but the
real big difference
as far as the displays is gaming
i was playing some games mostly call of
duty mobile on the 12
pro and i kept having that thought of
man i wish
the screen was bigger all the icons are
small i'm not seeing as much as far as
far away enemies
it's just so limiting and the experience
wasn't great now when i got the 12 pro
max in oh my goodness the difference in
gaming is dramatic so i would say if
you're somebody that plays games
often especially competitive games it is
awesome having that larger display
and now let's talk about the biggest
reason why some people want to move up
in size
to the max model when they've always had
a smaller iphone
and that is camera quality the pro max
not only has a 2.5 times telephoto lens
instead of a two times telephoto lens
but
the main sensor it actually has sensor
stabilization now
and with that a much larger sensor size
as well
that means it should help out in low
light photos and everything should be
smoother
honestly i didn't see that much of a
difference now
i have to say i haven't yet done a full
side-by-side
super detailed comparison we've been
working a lot on a lot of mac content
but early next week i will be doing an
ultimate camera comparison between the
12 pro max
the 12 pro and the regular 12 showing
you guys all the little
differences and we might do that blind
style you guys let us know
which way you want to do it either me
being analytical or having a little bit
more
fun so i was expecting the nighttime
photos to turn out a lot better
especially portraits being
sharper but it looked very similar to me
i didn't notice that much of a
difference and same thing with the
larger
sensor the portrait shots with the wide
lens looked
very similar to me as the regular 12 pro
and as far as zoom photos with the extra
telephoto zoom
on the 12 pro max the photos look almost
identical even side by side
let me know if you guys could tell a
quality difference down in the comments
section
now one thing i did notice is that the
12 pro max
would take a lot longer to take
telephoto shots at night
using the night mode instead of roughly
three seconds or so
it would take sometimes up to seven
eight seconds and that was really kind
of annoying and that's
that's because i think we have a longer
telephoto lens so it needs more time to
help with that shake and then with that
it doesn't let in as much light
as well so that was probably the biggest
thing that stood out to me now
of course we could have more differences
especially when we compare it side by
side so make sure you guys are
subscribed
so you guys see that video and you have
notifications enabled
but if i can't tell a difference when
i'm actually using it and trying to see
a difference
without putting them side by side and
being super critical
i would say that everybody's gonna be
happy with the 12 pro photos there's
been a lot of improvements from last
year and to wrap this up
i would say that if you're trying to get
the pro max model
just for the better cameras i would not
do it now with that
by far the biggest difference that i
noticed between these two
has to be the battery life i
really was not expecting this much of a
difference now both of these phones have
smaller batteries than the previous
years
and the 12 pro now has a larger display
than it did before
and so because of that the battery life
isn't great it definitely is a sacrifice
compared to last year
and for me it was kind of a shocker
moving from an 11 pro max because
instead of having all-day battery life
it would end up dying at about six to
seven o'clock
at that point i would need to plug it in
and top off
at least give it another 15-20 minutes
with a fast charger in order to make it
through
the day and i honestly was expecting to
not make it through a full day
with the 12 pro max but i was really
pleasantly surprised with the first
evening
after i used it a lot with the full day
and almost midnight
i still had about i think 17 battery
life here's a little screen recording
and every single day in this past week
not once have i had to top off this
phone and because of that that is going
to be the biggest reason why
i'm going to be keeping the 12 pro max
it is so nice
never to have to worry about battery
life just plug it in every night and
you're good to go
and with the power user like me that is
awesome now
take that along with the larger display
which is great for watching videos
especially great for gaming and the fact
that comfort wise
it is more comfortable than my 11 pro
max while having a larger display
and not that more cumbersome than the 12
pro
i'm gonna be sticking with this phone
from now on
i thought it was going to be because of
the cameras but no it's not
it's because of these other things that
i mentioned so there you guys go
those are all the real world differences
after one week of switching from the 12
pro to the 12
pro max make sure you guys click that
circle above if you guys want to see my
ultimate camera comparison
we're going to find out every single
little difference between these two
and the regular 12. click one of those
videos over there if you want to see
another great video
this max and i'll see you guys in the
next video
[Music]